bonjour misma à la dame merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france votre réaction à ce nouveau
scandale et ses passe-droits de certains
députés pour se faire vacciner
écoutez ici malheureusement c'est pas
étonnant parce que le clientélisme et le
népotisme c'est le critère principal qui
gouverne le liban à tous les niveaux
malheureusement et les gens se sont
plaints il ya une révolution qui a
commencé le 17 octobre dernier et le
parlement bon il ya huit députés qui ont
démissionné
mais bon jusqu'à maintenant rien n'a été
fait pour changer de façon de gérer la
situation en général
concernant les vaccins il y à sept ou
huit députés qui ont moins de 75 ans qui
ont été vaccinées hier les priorités qui
ont été établis en collaboration avec
les donateurs n'ont pas été observés le
corps médical n'a pas la priorité nous
avons reçu 25 mille vaccin est donc
vingt cinq mille vaccin serait à peine
suffisant pour le corps médical au liban
et pour les personnes qui ont donc pour
commencer à vacciner les personnes qui
ont de plus que 75 ans malheureusement
c'est une structure politique qui
résulte de toutes les milices qui ont
gouverné le pays pendant la guerre
civile dans les années 70 et qui sont
malheureusement toujours au pouvoir et
dernièrement ils ont transformé le
pouvoir au liban en un pouvoir
complètement répressif en
instrumentalisant l'appareil judiciaire
et les appareils de deux services
spéciaux et militaires pour maintenir
leur présence au pouvoir et leur
alliance régionale avec le régime
d'assad à travers les frontières
là vous parlez de la situation à tripoli
je pense avec les soulèvements qui ont
eu lieu on va en parler
restons sur la vaccination si vous ne
voulez bien pour l'instant
les libanais ont besoin de ces vaccins
on l'a vu dans le reportage
près d'un centre sur deux aussi ne
respecterait pas les les procédures de
vaccination
oui effectivement donc il ya eu dans des
centres beaucoup de personnes qui ont
été vaccinées et qu'il n'avait pas fait
la demande sur l'application internet
sur laquelle il devait le faire donc la
moitié de ceux qui ont été vaccinés ce
sont des gens qui sont présentés tout
simplement aux hôpitaux et on sépare sur
quelles bases donc la base est la
suivante probablement ce sont des gens
proches d aider des personnes au pouvoir
qui ont pu profiter de ces vaccins alors
que la population libanaise a
effectivement besoin il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui qui qui sont dans les
normes admises et qui n'ont pas reçu le
vaccin et la banque mondiale qui finance
ces vaccins et est monté au créneau
elles menacent maintenant de ne plus
financer même le beyrouth qui a besoin
des daims le liban qui a besoin d'être
parce qu'il ya une grave crise
économique également
absolument il ya une crise économique
qui est on y est nous avons encore trois
quatre mois pour pouvoir rattraper la
situation parce que vous savez les
produits de première nécessité sont
subventionnés par la banque centrale du
liban et les moyens sont limités à
quelques mois d'ici quelques mois si
jamais on n'avait pas si jamais on n'a
pas attrapé la situation économiquement
on risque de rentrer dans l'it à
l'inflation
et là vous savez que les les solutions
économiques seraient probablement
presque impossible comment ça se passe
au niveau des de la contestation avec ce
nouvel nouveau scandale de la
vaccination de la part de certains
députés
les libanais sont toujours en colère
écoutez les libanais sont en colère mais
ils font face à un régime qui devient de
plus en plus dépressifs ont finalement
même on parle de contestation sont des
contestations au niveau national tout le
monde se plaint vous savez que une
grande partie des des produits de
première nécessité qui sont
subventionnées par la banque centrale
passe en syrie plutôt que d'être utilisé
pour les libanais qui deviennent de plus
en plus pauvres on voit pour avoir une
idée allez les militaires qui avaient un
salaire plus ou moins de 1000 dollars
équivalent à 1000 dollars maintenant se
retrouve avec un salaire qui vaut pas
plus que 100 dollars là je parle des
militaires qui sont les mieux traités le
secteur public il ya à peu près 40% du
secteur public qui est qui qui a été
nommé par népotisme et clientélisme qui
profitent de salaire alors que
finalement ça faisait partie des
réformes dans la classe politique
s'était engagé pendant les accords de
cèdre avec les donateurs internationaux
et il ya également pardonnez moi il nous
reste peu de temps misbah ahdab il y a
également cessé protestataires qui ont
été arrêtés à tripoli il avait
manifester on en avait beaucoup parlé
sur notre antenne justement c'était des
émeutes quasiment de la faim qui se
déroulait dans cette grande ville
sunnite du liban
trente cinq protestataires arrêtés mis
en cause pour terrorisme expliquez vous
écoutez c'est une façon de tenir le
pouvoir donc finalement il ya des
groupes de qui sont utilisés par les les
services spéciaux qui sont proches des
politiciens qui essaient de 2,2 à lui de
mettre le feu ils ont mis le feu
d'ailleurs à la municipalité de tripoli
merci gens là n'ont pas été arrêtés les
les sols et les forces militaires qui
devaient protéger les bâtiments publics
n'était pas la personne n'y a pas eu de
d'interrogatoire qui revoit on n'a pas
eu de résultats si vous voulez sur deux
sur les enquêtes qui devait être fait
ils ont arrêté des activistes des
activistes qui effectivement avait
manifesté tout simplement pour cause de
fin il faut dire que tripoli
spécialement les rapports de l'espoir
depuis plus que dix ans nous avions déjà
des taux de 60% de pauvreté chose qui
maintenant malheureusement est devenu un
peu
partout présente partout au liban alors
que à l'époque bon c'était un cas
spécial parce qu'il y avait des
confrontations qui était également
provoqué à tripoli donc maintenant ce
qui se passe c'est un pays qui qui
rentre dans le chaos total
c'est un pouvoir qui essaient à travers
les structures étatiques de maintenir la
présence d des politiciens ou pouvoir
soutenu par le hezbollah et par
l'alliance régionale entre l'arizona et
le régime d'assad et le contrôle ils ont
sur les structures militaires libanaises
merci beaucoup misé bas à la dame
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france